In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for October 8th, on which we commemorate, Saint Thais,
the repentant harlot, Saint Thais lived at Alexandria in the 4th century.
When she was 17, her own mother placed her in a house of ill fame, where all who looked
on her great beauty were inflamed with lust.
She spent many years there and heaped up great fortune.
Saint Seraphion, the Sindenite, heard about the sinful woman Thais and was sent by God
to convert her.
Dressed as a soldier, he found her in the house, gave her a gold piece and went with her to
her room.
He asked, first of all, to speak to her for a few moments.
He explained the real reason for his visit and showed her the holy monastic habit that
he was wearing beneath his tunic.
As she listened to the holy monk, the young woman who knew that God is Almighty and that
an eternal punishment awaits sinners, awoke from the lethargy that had overcome her conscience
because of passion.
And when he went on to speak of the infinite mercy of God, who awaits the repentance of sinners,
that he may receive them in heaven with joy, Thais threw herself at the feet of Seraphion
and asked him to allow her but an hour before accepting to put her on the road of repentance,
by such means as he thought fit.
In the course of this hour, she hurried to the main square of the city and set fire to
the clothes, treasures, furniture, and everything she had got through unchastity, crying out
as she did so.
Come, all you who have shared in my harlotry, and watch me setting fire to everything I have
got by it, so as henceforth to give myself to repentance.
Then she went back to Seraphion, who took her to a monastery of virgins, and instructed
her to remain secluded in a cell for such time as God would reveal to her, eating but once
every two days and be teaching God's mercy at all times, with tears and groanings.
She did this for three years with ever increasing zeal and to the wonderment of all.
So Saint Seraphion went to visit Saint Antony the Great, at his monastery, to ask him if
God had accepted the sinful woman's repentance.
Saint Antony and his disciples spent a whole night in prayer and were given assurance in
a vision that Thais had been accounted worthy of the divine mercy.
Someone his return to the monastery, Seraphion, made the saint leave herself, even though
she considered herself unworthy and wished to remain there, in treating the mercy of God
until the end of her days.
Her prayer was soon granted for she dwelt but fifteen days among the other virgins before
she fell asleep in peace, allowing her soul to fly away to the choir of virgins who
wait about the marriage chamber of the heavenly bridegroom.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.